أحيانًا يتساقط الثلج في أوقات أخرى يكون
حادًا ، يمكن أن يكون ألمًا مستمرًا أو
حرقًا مفاجئًا ، إنه ألم
يعرف الجميع ما هو ولكن كيف يتم تخفيفه
عند لمس موقد ساخن عن طريق الخطأ
أو محاولة المشي على الكاحل الملتوي الذي
يستشعر الألم الأعصاب تسمى
يتم تشغيل مستقبلات الألم لإرسال
رسائل عصبية إلى عمودك الفقري وإلى
عقلك ، مما يؤدي إلى إطلاق دماغك
المواد الأفيونية التي تحدث بشكل طبيعي والتي
تحبس هذه المواد الكيميائية في المستقبلات الأفيونية في
جميع أنحاء جسمك للمساعدة في تخفيف
الألم وتهدئتك بشكل عام ،
كما أنها تصيب مستقبلات في جذع الدماغ
التي  تباطؤ التنفس الآن ، من
المحتمل أنك سمعت عن العقاقير الأفيونية مثل
أوكسيكودون هيدروكودون حتى الهيروين ،
كل هذه العقاقير المتشابهة كيميائيًا تحاكي تمامًا مادة
الإندورفين الطبيعية التي يصفها الجسم ، وهي واحدة
من أكثر الطرق شيوعًا للأطباء
لعلاج الألم ولكن كلما تناولت المزيد من المواد
الأفيونية  أقل من المواد الأفيونية التي يصنعها جسمك
وتصبح أقل حساسية
للأدوية التي تدفعك إلى تناولها بشكل متساوٍ
جرعات أعلى وأعلى للحصول على أي راحة
وزيادة فرص تناول جرعة زائدة
ولكن هناك طريقة أخرى يساعد جسمك في
تنظيم الألم أيضًا من خلال
النواقل العصبية التي تسمى
endocannabinoids عندما يشعر دماغك
أنك تتألم تمامًا كما هو الحال مع المواد الأفيونية
، يتم تحفيزها أيضًا لإنتاج
endocannabinoids  تحبس هذه المواد الكيميائية
في مستقبلات محددة في العمود الفقري
والدماغ للمساعدة في تخفيف الألم
وتقليل الالتهاب ولكن ليس في
جذع الدماغ ، لذلك لا يوجد خطر من تناول جرعة زائدة ،
اعتبر الماريجوانا الخاصة بجسمك في
الواقع سميت على اسم
نبات القنب ولهذا السبب كثيرًا  من
الناس يتحولون إلى جرعات حبوب منع الحمل
لك